I am home on vacation visiting family
and somehow I've ended up sick
so
I decided to get a Nutty pot I've never
used a Neti Pot before and I'm a little
scared also I got distilled water
because my stepsister told me that if I
did it with tap water I would get a
brain eating amoeba I do not want a
brain eating amoeba daddy pot first try
users should start with one packet done
fill the pot to the eight ounce bag with
proper water with proper water Bean
this is a very strange feeling
oh
I mean it feels weird don't get me wrong
but I feel great now probably be using
it like way more times in the next 24
hours
if you can't breathe through your nose
or you're you're dripping with no end in
sight try it